[Music]
what was it like the transformation for
this movie to become Peter now it was uh
it was rough rugged and raw you know
um
you know as an actor you're you're
looking for that moment when you get it
right so when you know there's a there's
a magic moment you never you don't know
if you will get it yep
that we were testing the neck chains
right and it was probably six weeks out
and I put it on and they had you know
old school you know replicas and he put
the key in and it it didn't work and he
couldn't get it off
and it was I was locked in it for about
15 minutes
for real and they're scrambling around
and my mind is going crazy as I'm
standing there with these chains locked
on and then all of a sudden I just
understood
I just got it you know yeah I felt what
what you know uh a taste of what it what
it must have felt like I had people
scrambling around trying to get it off
me and Peter didn't
I find them
they beat me
with me
they break the bones
in my body
more times than I can count
the journey for Peter is unbelievable
what has the journey been like for you
these last few months oh no you know
that Peter has been in my heart in a
beautiful way you know the uh the
recognition of the relationship between
suffering and salvation you know that
that
realization that uh nobody gets out of
bearing their cross you know and you
know it's just been a uh a really
beautiful a beautiful a beautiful
transformation let's get to Baton Rouge
for this one
there are many ways to die in a swamp
I want to ask you then about what was it
like being in the swamp it was hot it
was clearly I mean you were swimming you
were rolling in the mud what was that
like now you know it's uh those swamps
are not a place for a human being right
to be out there trying to survive you
know so
um
you know being able to be in some of the
actual locations that that Peter was in
and it was a it was a huge education for
me I had seen the picture before and I
didn't
I didn't know anything about it
um but then to to be out there to
experience it like all of those whip
marks now have stories behind them in in
my mind you know tell me about fighting
the alligator yeah ah yeah no so we were
out there in the swamps for real so what
you don't want to hear as an actor is
God God get well out get well out we got
a gator get will out yeah so that that
happened out there a couple of times so
wow yeah last thing I've been on those
plantations in River row and when you
see people dressed the way you were
dressed in authentic gear it does
something to your mind and your psyche
what did it do to you and also how did
you Channel Peter to being a superhero
so that you don't feel like this is a
slave move yeah you know the the
being in those locations and in that
wardrobe it's like
the level of Cruelty that humans can
commit against one another
[Music]
um is excruciating
um to be on that Plantation you know
there were people there there were the
background actors there who had family
you know 60 70 80 100 years ago so they
had family stories right you know so it
was um it was life-changing for me man
[Music]
foreign
[Music]